es gibt neues vom weltklimarat der sagt
jetzt wir könnten die erderwärmung
vielleicht doch noch auf 1,5 grad
begrenzen
jetzt aber die schlechte nachricht dazu
müssen wir sofort zu drastischen
maßnahmen greifen ja stand so in der
neuen energiewende ist gar nicht komisch
drastische maßnahmen das heißt konkret
bis 2050 müssten die co2-emissionen auf
null runter auf 0 worauf unser
zuständiger minister für wirtschaft und
energie gesagt hat wo er recht hat hat
er recht
ja nur mal zur erinnerung im pariser
klimaabkommen steht wir wollen ganz
wichtig wir wollen die erderwärmung auf
deutlich unter zwei grad begrenzen so
besser werden aber 1,5 grad denn dieses
halbe grad macht echt ganz schön viel
aus beim meeresspiegelanstieg hier
norddeutschland heute und bei zwei grad
plus
ich sag mal so wenn sie in cuxhaven
wohnen würde ich jetzt noch schnell mein
seepferdchen machen über drei millionen
deutsche über drei millionen deutsche
leben aktuell in gebieten die dann
bedroht sind bis 2020 wollte deutschland
40 prozent weniger co2 schaffen wenn es
gut läuft wir 32 dass jetzt der trend
global einfach alles mögliche
unterschreiben aber dann bei den
nationalen maßnahmen [ __ ]
sicher müssen wir zugeben das
abschmelzen der polkappen hat natürlich
nicht nur nachteile
die reduktion des polaren meereises wird
chancen auch beinhalten zum beispiel die
entfernung
hamburg tokio ich musste sich von 21.000
kilometer auf 13.000 km reduzieren
ist doch super oder
ist das toll für all die pendler die
morgens immer von braunschweig nach
tokio müssen ist so toll ja kein wunder
dass viele bürger den klimawandel nicht
mehr so richtig als frage von leben und
tod ernst nehmen so wie sich die
regierungen gerade verhalten auch unsere
wir müssen jetzt etwas tun verkehrswende
stadt autoindustrie schon das ist den
leuten oft nicht klar wir müssen auf
null emissionen
das bedeutet das können sie nicht
erreichen damit dass sie weniger auto
fahren das heißt der auto muss was
anderes machen als co2 ausstoß mein auto
kann aber nichts anderes als co2
ausstoßen was soll das denn noch lernen
sein alter der hier muss endlich mal ein
quark um unser energiewende minister
peter altmaier oder die enge freundinnen
später altmaier
ja das ist kein witz wir liegen hinten
bei autos gnadenlos bei stromtrassen bei
allem die reden jetzt in berlin nur noch
von 2030 und vom jahr 2050 aber dann
römer dann erreichen wir sämtliche ziele
so eine einstellung entschleunigt enorm
sollten wir privat vielleicht auch so
machen
du hast tierisch viel zu erledigen aber
einfach keinen bock
dann hol dir jetzt machst doch
irgendwann mal die neue app die alle
wichtigen termine immer weiter nach
hinten schiebt müll rausbringen zum
zahnarzt gehen steuererklärung sport klo
putzen machst doch irgendwann mal
basso hatte mal die kinder von der
schule abholen kein problem mache ich
circa 50 jahren die neue jetzt unseren
guten uhr die nächste runde kann nicht
stolz drauf
macht man mal machst doch irgendwann mal
genau in diesem geist ist unsere umwelt
ministerin svenja schulze diese woche
zum treffen der umweltminister nach
luxemburg gereist
direkt nach erscheinen des neuen
alarmierenden klimaberichts musste sie
im auftrag ihrer kanzlerin die eu
kollegen von strengeren co2 auflagen für
autos abhalten abhalten vorher hat die
merkel leider auch war persönlich die
anderen regierungschefs angerufen jena
ist ein angerufen und gesagt maximal 30
prozent weniger mehr können wir unsere
abend deutschen autoindustrie nicht
zumuten
zum glück konnte sich am ende nicht ganz
durchsetzen und immerhin hat das
umweltministerium jetzt ein ganz neues
maskottchen und zwar passend zu der
politik die da machen
die erde wollen und nur einer kann uns
retten der umwelt superheld klima
[Musik]
im auftrag seiner ministerin es heute
alle phrasen raus die das ängstliche
volk hören will
der klimawandel ist eine schicksalsfrage
wir dürfen beim klimaschutz keine zeit
mehr verlieren sachen blues captain
klima greift namenlos durch wenn der
droge mal wieder zu viel fleisch oder
wenn ein häuslebauer seine wand fall
stimmt
ja aber das bringt doch alles nichts
wenn die regierung weiter die hand über
kohle und autoindustrie hält
umweltschutz darf nie auf kosten von
arbeitsplätzen geld wir haben uns die
erde von unseren kindern nur geliehen
man sieht die scheiße aus von hier oben
cooper da der brand von meppen brett
schon wieder leute wir brauchen die
energiewende die umstieg in die
erneuerbaren aber sanft muss er sein
beispiel windkraft da kann man nicht
einfach
[Musik]